yesterday's big story is that facebook
had gone dark so facebook went dark for
about six hours yesterday
and um
the facebook stock dropped it apparently
was some sort of hack
facebook and instagram were down for
some amount of hours
yesterday and
this prompted a lot of talk about
facebook and its evil this was also
prompted by a facebook whistleblower
named francis hogan who is on 60 minutes
this is all in preparation for a
democratic full-frontal assault on
facebook his facebook whistleblower was
talking about how instagram in
particular
had done internal research and they
found that shock of shocks teenage girls
were not doing well after using
instagram
now this has been true of pretty much
everything in media for as long as i've
been alive it turns out the research
shows that girls looking at glossy
magazines like cosmopolitan not
particularly good for self-image
that any sort of chat room for girls any
sort of interconnection for teenage
girls that is outside of sort of the
interpersonal
really is not great for mental health
but francis hogan over at facebook is
now a whistleblower and she's a
whistleblower because there's an attempt
right now by democrats to basically take
facebook down a peg
the story of facebook is kind of
fascinating in the sense that it used to
be celebrated by the left now it has
become
persona non grata
enemy number one
for the left
again facebook went down yesterday and
that was kind of the big news but the
really big news is the coordinated
assault on facebook that is now
happening by democratic media and
politicians right it is a coordinated
assault
so to understand exactly what they're
doing facebook you have to understand
why facebook is a danger to the
democratic media complex
so before 2016 facebook was a darling of
the left
facebook had been used to great success
by barack obama in 2012 to mobilize all
the people who are going to vote for him
and to organize on the ground
facebook was this great godsend if you
go back and look at the media coverage
of facebook circa 2010 2011 2012 it was
very largely positive
and then something happened something
that happened was 2016. in 2016 donald
trump won and when donald trump won the
left started to look for a bogeyman they
couldn't blame hillary clinton they
couldn't blame themselves because they
had convinced themselves after 2012 that
they had a durable never to lose
coalition they had a coalition that
would never be defeated electorally
again it was a coalition of the
dispossessed as african-americans for
barack obama and gays for barack obama
and hispanics for barack obama and
college-educated white liberals for
barack obama and this coalition when you
put them all together would never lose
again and then trump won
and for a brief moment in time in the
media there was this moment where they
said maybe we've missed something maybe
maybe we should go out and actually talk
to people instead of just considering
them evil horrific deplorables
and then the moment ended and they
decided no it can't be us who's we are
not wrong it's the children who are
wrong they're full principle skinner
from the simpsons
and they decided facebook was the
problem it had been facebook because if
facebook had not allowed all of this
dissemination of speech then presumably
hillary clinton would have won
and the way that they tried to cover for
the fact that they don't like freedom of
speech is by saying it was russian
interference on facebook now anybody who
actually looked at the stats on russian
interference on facebook understand that
the amount of actual dissemination of
russian material was extremely low
in the number of people actually
affected by russian disinformation the
senate did a full report and they were
putting up posts that were supposedly
the election shifters that had like a
thousand shares
yeah i had more shares from my facebook
page in a month than the entire
quote-unquote russian operation had in
over a year did i shift the entire
election in favor of donald trump of
course not it's very silly
but the media had to go with this
narrative because of course somebody had
to pay and it turns out that this
narrative also allowed the democratic
media establishment to try and
re-establish the monopoly on
informational dissemination that they
have been seeking since the rise of
alternative media
back in the 60s 70s there were only a
few daily papers that were national the
new york times the washington post the
wall street journal
there were only a couple of channels
that were national abc cbs nbc that's
where you got your news and there were
some local news channels that was it
and then with the rise of the internet
there came this ability to actually
critique and find alternative viewpoints
on on stories and sometimes find
alternative stories that were just not
covered by the media and this started to
eat into the media's market share
and so the media had two choices
and you've seen them take both one was
they could double down on their base
this is why the new york times is now
indistinguishable from salon.com
or
and right because they did both they
could attempt to crack down on the
methods of dissemination of information
and re-establish a media monopoly
and the way they would do that is by
cuddling facebook into suppressing
traffic from their competitors
the idea was if we can re-establish the
dominance of legacy media then things
will go back to normal it'll help us
it'll help us the media in our quest for
oligarchic control of informational
dissemination and market share and it'll
help democrats because of course all of
the major outlets the legacy media
outlets in american life those outlets
all slam to the left and coordinate
pretty openly with the democratic party
it's the latest assault on facebook is
part of this understand nobody in the
media truly cares about instagram and
its effect on teenage girls it's been
the right largely it has been very
critical of kids using the internet in
these ways for years and years and years
and years i'm not letting my kids use
the internet until they're essentially
18.
i have no intention of letting my kids
traffic around on instagram
with that said
the democrats were kind of happy with
all this stuff right social media is
where you go for approval when you're
gender transitioning social media is
where you go when you come out of the
closet social media is where you go when
you're looking for support for a fringe
left-wing position social media is where
you go when you're coordinating the
revolution
social media is how you escape the bonds
of your confinement at your home and
find a more sympathetic audience
and these are the the things that many
members of the left have been saying for
years and years and years now they're
very upset however with these exact same
services on a very selective level so
understand that the attack on instagram
really is not about instagram
right the left is not looking to crack
down on instagram in any serious way
what they're looking to do is force
zuckerberg and force facebook and force
all of these outlets into compliance
with what they believe should be the
informational dissemination rules
so the latest element of this attack is
the facebook whistleblower francis hogan
so she was on 60 minutes talking about
how facebook had information that
instagram was damaging to teenage girls
and they continued to operate their
business
francis haugen plans to testify before
congress this week
she believes the federal government
should impose regulations
facebook has demonstrated they cannot
act independently facebook over and over
again has shown it uses profit over
safety it is subsidizing is paying for
its profits with our safety i'm hoping
that this will have had a big enough
impact on the world
that they get the fortitude and the
motivation to actually go put those
regulations into place
okay so understand the whistleblower
didn't whistle blow on anything
right she didn't actually give you any
information you didn't already have was
there anybody in america who is unaware
that instagram is damaging to teenage
girls has been known for quite a while
that again teenage girls online in a
wide variety of settings coordinating
with one another is very typically not a
wonderful thing teenage boys too right
teenagers generally coordinating with
each other like teenagers are not fully
developed brain wise and they tend to
make really dumb decisions and when
they're networked with each other the
decisions get dumber and dumber and this
has been true for a very long time but
why are the media playing this up so
facebook responded to this report from
60 minutes they said every day our teams
have to balance protecting the right of
billions of people to express themselves
openly with the need to keep our
platform a safe and positive place we
continue to make significant
improvements to tackle the spread of
misinformation and harmful content to
suggest we encourage bad content and do
nothing is just not true
they said we've invested heavily in
people and technology to keep our
platform safe and have made fighting
misinformation and providing
authoritative information a priority if
any research had identified an exact
solution to these complex challenges the
tech industry governments and society
would have solved them a long time ago
we have a strong track record of using
our research to inform changes to our
app
they say hosting hateful or harmful
content is bad for our community bad for
advertisers and ultimately bad for our
business our incentive is to provide a
safe meaningful experience for billions
of people who use facebook
and they say that the goal of meaningful
social interactions there's a metric
called meaningful social interactions
which is what they use to boost traffic
on particular posts they say the goal of
the meaningful social interactions
ranking change is in the name improve
people's experience by prioritizing
posts that inspire interactions
particularly conversations between
friends and family which research shows
is better for people's well-being and
deep prioritizing public content
research shows polarization's been
growing in the united states for a
decade
so again what facebook is saying here
because most of what this report has
been focused on in the media is
instagram but the other part of the
whistleblower talk is how facebook is
prioritizing quote unquote hate speech
and how they're incentivizing hate
speech okay understand why the media is
covering that they're saying that
because when they say hate speech what
they mean is shows they don't like and
people talking they don't like they mean
the new york post story on hunter biden
they mean shows like this one they mean
information disseminated from the daily
wire that is what they mean
and that is very clearly what they're
attempting to do it is no coincidence
that the facebook whistleblower is a
long-time democratic donor
according to the national pulse she
donated 36 times to democrats including
to aoc
okay that is that is not a shock in any
way shape or form
it is also not a shock that the top
democratic operative bill burton is
advising the facebook whistleblower
according to the washington free beacon
she's getting strategic communications
guidance from a top democratic operative
is now deeply integrated with an
emerging infrastructure on the left
comprised of individuals and
organizations including the non-profit
center for humane technology seeking to
press facebook to more aggressively
police political content
in hogan's public testimony industry and
political insiders see a sophisticated
communications campaign intended to put
facebook on defense from a steady
trickle of leaked internal documents
that fueled a wall street journal
investigative series dubbed the facebook
files to the blockbuster 60 minutes
interview to congressional testimony
scheduled to begin on tuesday
hugging 60 minutes interview kicked off
a media feeding frenzy with the story
mentioned at least 200 times on cable
news since the segment aired
burton's involvement helping to manage
hogan's public debut suggests her
argument is part of a broader democratic
initiative this of course is exactly
true because remember the goal of the
democrats is to get facebook to crack
down on information that democrats do
not like
that is the goal
and it's coming from the white house by
the way this is coordinated here is jen
saki explaining that what this
whistleblower interview shows that
quote-unquote self-regulation isn't
working okay now as facebook says what
sort of regulation would actually work
here
right there there's
it's very funny there are people on the
right who say well you know we on the
left and the right we can agree that
facebook needs to be regulated okay what
you don't understand if you say that is
that the way that the right wants to
regulate facebook is by forcing facebook
to allow more content the way that the
left wishes to regulate facebook is by
forcing facebook to allow less content
that is a fundamental debate that is not
going to be bridged here here's jen saki
essentially calling for censorship
in our view this is just the latest in a
series of revelations about social media
platforms that make clear that
self-regulation is not working that's
long been the president's view and been
the view of this administration they
validate the significant concern that
the president lawmakers on both sides of
the aisle have expressed about how
social media giants operate and the
power they've
amassed okay understand that what this
really is is government control okay
they are looking for government control
margaret sullivan the columnist for the
washington post she says what we really
should be pushing for here is get ready
for a new federal agency focused on the
digital economy hey more federal
government that'll be the solution
remember that part where it said
congress shall not abridge freedom of
speech remember that part yeah that's
that's gone we need a new federal agency
that is given the power to effectively
just slap any company that disseminates
information that democrats don't like i
guess it's presumably the way this would
work
the idea comes from none other than a
former fcc chairman tom wheeler who
maintains that neither his agency nor
the federal trade commission are nimble
or tech savvy enough to protect
consumers in a volatile and evolving
industry you need an agency that doesn't
say here are the rigid rules when the
rules become obsolete almost immediately
said wheeler
so if we really want to think about the
public interest in the fast-paced
digital world it will be necessary to
revise the cumbersome top-down
rule-making process that has been in
place since the industrial era wheeler
wrote in a harvard shorenstein center
paper
digital platforms like facebook and
google have become pseudo governments
that make the rules said wheeler so
instead what they need are a bunch of
people in government who don't actually
have to say what the rules are they can
just go around and do exactly what they
want
the the it's kind of an incredible thing
that they're calling for i mean they're
calling for for pretty much top-down
tyranny you know the rule of law
requires that you have easily
interpretable neutrally applicable rules
what's being called for by margaret
sullivan is a government agency that has
no rules but has nearly unlimited power
over this area of american life
now listen facebook has made its own bed
here in some ways because for years
facebook stood up to the left and then
facebook started to collapse to the left
i mean back in 2019 mark zuckerberg said
at georgetown university quote people no
longer have to rely on traditional
gatekeepers and politics or media to
make their voices heard that has
important consequences i understand the
concerns about how tech platforms have
centralized power but i actually believe
the much bigger story is how much these
platforms have decentralized power by
putting it directly into people's hands
and this is when zuckerberg was a big
free speech advocate
and then the left put so much pressure
on that facebook started to suppress
information
apparently in the belief that if they
were nice to the left the left would
leave them alone wrong
once the left's got its foot in the door
now the left is going to go the rest of
the way and they are going to go after
facebook and you know we on the right
again a lot of people on the right are
very skeptical of facebook i think that
skepticism is in many ways justified as
i'll discuss in a moment
but understand that if facebook gets
shut down or facebook gets restricted by
the federal government
the outlets that are going to suffer are
not the new york times or cnn or msnbc
all of the competitive brands
because those competitive brands have
been using facebook as a distribution
platform in new media
all these other platforms we're talking
about have been around for 30 years
daily wear has been around since 2015.
that's why there is a coordinated
campaign against the spigot if facebook
is the spigot the goal of the left is to
shut off the spigot your access to
information that's what this is really
about you don't have to love zuckerberg
to believe that now if you love facebook
to believe that you can be very critical
of facebook's willingness to concede to
exactly the people seeking to shut off
the spigot which we'll discuss in a
moment
but you gotta understand what exactly
they're trying to do because it is
perfectly obvious at this point okay so
to understand exactly how much facebook
has already caved to the left you have
to kind of look at their new standards
so
a few weeks ago facebook put out a
notice as to how they distribute content
their content distribution guidelines so
here at the daily wire over the last
year right just before the election it
became very clear that facebook had
changed its standards and was now
suppressing content we could see it in
our traffic stats we could see how
facebook had started to suppress our
traffic essentially and now they are
admitting exactly how they do this
and the way that they do this is by
setting standards that explicitly
benefit the legacy media and so there's
a certain irony to the legacy media now
using that as a as a foot in the doorway
to just ram through all the way and
destroy facebook wholesale as always
cowardice is met not
with some sort of conciliatory approval
by those who are seeking a concession
cowardice is met with abject humiliation
if you are a coward they will come and
they will destroy your business if you
are a coward and you give one inch to
the left the left will come in and they
will break you they will destroy what
you have built
and so facebook gave much more than an
inch
remember facebook's original pitch was
we are here to allow as many people as
possible to engage with as many sources
as humanly possible because you live in
a world of choice and this will allow
people to actually get access to
information and social networks they
otherwise would not have been a part of
and then facebook shifted in 2018 2019
2020 they started talking about their
responsibility to call out information
that they thought was bad not
information that was overtly false not
information that was so far outside the
overton window that it bordered on the
violent right not any of that they
decided they were going to call out
mainstream information and they were
going to suppress mainstream information
so long as that information came from a
non-approved political point of view and
now they're making that perfectly clear
right so here are their standards that
they admitted to having for the past
year
and this kind of stuff does affect
elections gang
what did they do they said that they
were going to suppress content from
domains with limited original content
they said they're going to crack down on
content that quote contains a large
amount of content from other publishers
that has been copied or only slightly
modified usually for the purposes of
increasing web page volume and driving
traffic
now that is explicitly directed at
places that don't have massive
journalistic budgets
right because the reality is that most
sites rely on a certain amount of
aggregation in fact even the mainstream
media relies on a certain amount of
aggregation how many times have you seen
a story from the new york times
laundered into the washington post as a
rewrite of the new york times story it
happens all the time
but facebook was only going to crack
down on one type of site for this sort
of activity
then facebook said they were going to
crack down on traffic rooted in fact
checked misinformation
so they downgraded quote content that
has been debunked as false altered or
partly false by nonpartisan third party
fact checking organizations who partner
with facebook and have been certified by
the international fact-checking
organization
so as we've deal as we've detailed
expansively on this show and at daily
wire fact-checking organizations who
have been approved by the so-called
international fact-checking network are
almost entirely left-wing propaganda
agencies dedicated to the upholding of
left-wing lies and the suppression of
right-wing truths
so if you say things that are true fact
checkers will very often suggest that
you have said something that is false
this sort of stuff happens like all the
time it will say that you are missing
context
they'll admit openly that what you're
saying is true in the body of the piece
and then they will say mixed their
rating will be mixed meanwhile if you're
leftist and you say something overtly
false
like the cost of the
buildback better agenda is zero
they will say that it's mostly true
because it's covered by tax dollars
right the fact-checking organizations
are propaganda outlets so basically
facebook outsourced to a bunch of
left-wing propaganda outlets the ability
to suppress traffic from anybody who
disagrees facebook also said they would
cut down on quote-unquote inauthentic
sharing according to facebook link posts
will be reduced when they are shared a
high number of times and the majority of
that sharing comes from accounts that
recently and repeatedly engaged in
hyper-sharing content relative to the
average person who uses our service so
in other words if the most excited
people tend to retweet daily wire
articles or or repost them on facebook
then the content will be suppressed
you have to have the average joe who may
not be all that politically aware or
informed tweeting out stuff or putting
it up on facebook in order for facebook
to allow the traffic to aggregate
facebook cut down
on traffic from links to domains and
pages with a high quote-unquote click
gap
according to facebook
they restricted links to websites that
receive a particularly disproportionate
amount of their traffic directly from
facebook compared to the amount of
traffic the websites receive from the
rest of the internet
it is a perfect example of so-called
regulatory capture by the legacy media
the legacy media's existed for literally
over a century
they've built up this wellspring of
people who are subscribers and who click
on their stuff organically for those of
us who had to start our companies in the
last 10 years a lot a large amount of
our traffic comes from the place where
the eyeballs are facebook facebook is
now saying if too high a percentage of
your traffic comes from facebook we will
crack down on your traffic
so we are explicitly cracking down on
the places that are new media in favor
of the places that are old media
it's like a billboard agency deciding to
reject advertisements from a startup
restaurant because too many customers on
a percentage basis are coming into the
restaurant based on the billboard rather
than coming in based on quote unquote
organic traffic that would obviously cut
very much in favor of legacy
organizations like mcdonald's or kfc and
not in favor of the new startup
restaurant that is simply trying to get
people to come in by using billboards
facebook says they're going to suppress
articles that are coming from quote
non-transparent authorship so if you use
a staff byline or if somebody uses a
pseudonym online to avoid the the
evil political climate we've created
where people are targeted in their homes
then they're going to crack down on that
and they cut down on posts from quote
unquote broadly untrusted news
publishers
what exactly is broadly untrusted how
exactly ought that to be decided
broadly untrusted according to facebook
means that you have to have people from
all sides of the political aisle that
say that they trust you who do you think
that's going to benefit that's not going
to benefit the new media or overt about
their their biases it's going to benefit
the old media who lie about them
hey and they said they were going to
suppress content that was borderline to
the community standards including
content that does not violate covenant
19 or vaccine policies but which shares
misleading or sensationalized
information about vaccines in a way that
would be likely to discourage
vaccinations which means they really
should be cracking down on joe biden and
anthony fauci but instead they're
cracking down on the right the point
that i'm making here is that facebook
has already spent years attempting to
placate the left and now the left is
seeking to destroy facebook all the way
they're seeking to destroy facebook
wholesale
if you can't spot what it is they're
trying to do
you're gonna miss exactly why all of a
sudden there's all this information that
is coming out about facebook it has
nothing to do with the goodwill of the
media and the attempts to crack down on
bad behavior by massive social media
companies it's not about that it's about
cracking down on your ability to access
the information that you want by the
democrat media complex in coordination
with some insiders at facebook itself
i know what you're thinking it's time to
bin some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video